the massive covid vaccine rollout is
requiring the use of big spaces like
stadiums for vaccinations
delta airlines has partnered with the
state of georgia to create free
vaccination sites
inside and near hartsfield-jackson
atlanta international airport one of the
busiest in the country
more than 3 million doses have been
administered across the state of georgia
including
about 39 000 people at the airport errol
barnett got an exclusive look inside the
airport site
and joins us from delta's nearby museum
errol wherever you can get the shots
let's do that good morning to you
that's the idea gail good morning look
any other year this would be the main
attraction right visitors want to get up
close
to the spirit of delta but now that's
just a bonus in one of three locations
the airline
is using to get those life-saving shots
in the arm to employees
and the general public freestyles
yes perfect after 36 years as a pilot
captain bill barnes knows the importance
of punctuality
time is important to me and this is very
quick and very
convenient this delta veteran is among
thousands of airline
and airport staff getting vaccinated
inside hartsville jackson's concours
c this week formerly busy gates have
been converted into clinics
from check-in to a number system and
those long-awaited
shots airport employee roderick jackson
got vaccinated
while working he says the benefits are
immense
i'm afraid of the other end more so than
afraid of this
you know the other end is death why
would you not
want something to give you more of an
opportunity a chance at life
outside in the shadow of an old 747
delta is providing even
more space for any georgian to get
vaccinated
sherry russo runs this operation the
state's busiest
outdoor vaccination site so we're
averaging right now about 2200 doses a
day
and starting monday we'll go 3 000 doses
a day and
currently we're right around 39 000
total doses in about five weeks
how long can you keep this up we're
going to be here a minimum of 13 weeks
and that might be extended depending
upon what the governor and dr timmy say
dr henry ting is delta's first chief
health officer
i think we're ready to reclaim our lives
as well as reclaim our joy and we'll get
there by ending this pandemic with
the vaccination and for most the step
toward joy
took mere minutes i may have been here
eight minutes
eight minutes isn't even a lunch break
that's what i'm saying it's a bathroom
break
now look delta won't say what this costs
but certainly it cannot get
back to a full schedule until everyone
is vaccinated so there is some
self-interest here but i can tell you
beyond the joy that i'm seeing in all of
these locations there's
another measurement of how well things
are going the man who runs the state's
emergency agency told me
that he received a compliment he's quite
proud of that even the homegrown
food chain chick-fil-a would be proud of
the efficiency happening here
tony that's a high bar there errol thank
you very much hey you know i'm curious i
happen to be a delta diamond member and
how did delta get involved in this not
some other airlines
well here's the deal this is delta's hub
and base and the state reached out to
an organization that could provide the
space needed
to vaccinate so many people the head of
jima that's the state's emergency agency
said
they needed to connect with an
operational expert delta knows how to
run things so that skill set
and that partnership is now resulting in
roughly 40 000 doses administered
already and there's no plans to stop
this anytime soon
all right great shot barnett thank you
very much errol barnett that's a great
shot
behind you i love the shot of the plane
and it just shows what ed bastian who
runs delta knows what he's doing
but i'm still fascinated by the guy that
has an eight minute back
i want to know what you're doing in the
bathroom at eight minutes maybe a long
time
walk together pick a book sir